my next guest had me scared right down
on my socks in a particular Rose Bowl
back in the day taking on my my
Wolverines for Washington State he's the
host of pac-12 this morning every single
day on Channel seventh pardon me set
channel 373 on sirius XM radio between
the hours of 7:00 and 10:00 Pacific in
the morning so that's at 10:00 to 1:00
in the afternoon Eastern Time Fox Sports
1 college football analyst he is Ryan
Leaf good to see you sir you too Thanks
first things first how are you doing I'm
good I'm busy I'm a dad of a
nine-month-old today so it's a birthday
of your son yeah my son guy my guy
MacGyver Leif yep is that named after
amazing it was yeah my wife-to-be Ana
actually picked it out she we spell it
different we spell MC g yv ER okay and
it just you know at first everybody is
kind of like really and then they're
like okay and then people really seem to
like any it fits him he's he's getting
out of jams he's getting he's bubblegum
and all of a sudden wait a minute he was
in the crib and now dammit we're he's on
the roof he's 2 now feet tall already
come on yeah he was 2 feet at Birth so
well Anna and as a former volleyball
player she's 6 foot 1 so when you're 6 6
6 6 yeah Wow
into jeans man yeah has he already
committed to Coach Saban put in a wanted
a verbal but we were you know Jim Jim
taught me really how to play
professional football he was my backup
in San Diego was he really yeah so he
was really close friend of mine and he
he pretty much taught me how to be a
professional after those first that
first year where I struggled so much he
taught me how to go about do it what do
you teach you about they taught me about
how to be competitive I was thought I
was always competitive and then I came
up across a guy who was in the last
pretty much two years of his NFL career
and we went at it and then when I won
the job he relinquished that and looked
at me and came into the a quarterback
room every week just there to help me
try to make me better so we could win as
a team he wanted to win regard
this he didn't care if he was a starting
quarterback or not and I think that's
what makes him such a great coach his
ability to coach every single one of his
kids to try to be the best and who can
contribute each week so what about
teaching you how to be a professional in
terms of being ready for situations
dealing with the media did he talk about
that - yeah he helped me a lot if you if
you see really from like what that
rookie year looked like - year three
after I hurt my wrist and I wasn't as
physically capable of playing the
demeanor of how I was in Tampa and
Dallas and how I treated the media and
it was a different kind of person I just
wasn't physically talented enough to
compete at that level which is you know
something I wish I would have learned
earlier of course but I mean he's helped
me now down the line later in life and
this type of life now to be more
accountable for my actions and things of
that nature he was a you know was a big
part of what my early life was like huh
Jim Harbaugh huh Ryan Leaf here on the
Rich Eisen show so let's let's get into
some what what you're up to and what's
been going on and some headlines to get
your thoughts I want to talk about Tyler
Olinsky with you as a Washington State
quarterback we all know what happened to
Tyler and those who don't
21 year old young man taking his own
life with an ar-15 out of the blue I
mean just out of the complete blue to
all of the people who knew him and loved
him and then the Mayo Clinic checking
him out to say that he had early stages
of CTE in his brain what are your
thoughts on the first of all the the the
first thought that comes to me is the
the end of stigma mantra that we need to
continue with we have the stigma of what
mental health is in this country is is
one of weakness we when we see it on the
platform people actually talking about
it because like oh that must be changing
but really in culture it's not it's it's
seen as a weakness we don't stand up as
strong football players and say we're
struggling with something or we don't
see on movies or in the past that the
valedictorian are the most popular kid
in the school or or the star quarterback
is not standing in front of a group of
his peers saying hey everybody out I'm
struggling with this otherwise I would
have been that guy in San Diego right I
would have stood up in front of my team
and say guys I need your help I don't
know what the heck I'm doing here
trying to be your leader instead I am
just a mess in I get backed into a
corner and I figure my only way out is
to fight luckily for me at that time I
didn't have those suicidal thoughts I
got to that place you know when about
seven years ago you know at the height
of my my substance abuse and just the
you know no mental health treatment you
know I was just I was self-medicating
that's all that the substance was for me
and I was at that place so when that
night that had happened and I read about
it my first instinct was was anger
because I was just at the Holiday Bowl I
just sat down at breakfast with those
quarterbacks with Tyler and he knew what
I had gone through and yet he still
didn't feel comfortable enough to cuz I
was I was right there I'd have been a
guy that that could have related to him
so that was what I was most angry about
I was also kind of resentful of myself
that I hadn't reached out to Washington
State sooner where I said let me come I
don't care you know what our past looks
like I wanted if I was standing in that
room telling that group of men my story
and talking about how it's okay it's not
a weakness but actually the strongest
thing you'll ever do is to be vulnerable
and show that side of you um you know
maybe we're not sitting here with this
now and makes more sense now because of
the diagnosis and it it kind of
reaffirmed something that I've been
feeling and thinking for a long time
there's a lot of us probably who have
played whether it's in high school
college there's just not enough data out
there right now cuz we've studied all
the brains of the NFL players who have
died but what happens when we test
somebody's brain who's died at 30 or 40
years old of mental health issues
how much football did he play or how
much head trauma did he have so I
believe that there's a lot of us
including me that are living with some
form of CTE right now the difference is
is that I think the substance abuse part
for me made me address it and seek
treatment in and find positive
alternatives to what these symptoms look
like because we can't diagnosis until
post mortem but we do know what the
symptoms look like now and there are
healthy alternatives
tried to the biggest reason this most
people will dealt with this issue their
answer was to take their own life
instead of finding a healthy alternative
and what that may look like and that's
where we're at right now and hopefully
with this diagnosis and I'd really think
this is gonna be a water shed moment
when a 21 year old is diagnosed with
that post mortem that there's an issue
and it's not just the NFL but finding
safer ways to play football in
particular what Brett Farr has been
saying lately about removing the contact
before you're at least 12 and and I have
made the deal where MacGyver can't wear
a helmet till he's 15 and then we're
gonna give them all the information and
who knows what 15 years from now this
will look like sure but that's gonna be
our deal we're not gonna let him wear a
helmet at least 15 and then we're gonna
give them all them information we can
and let him make that choice Ryan Leaf
here on the Rich Eisen show and what's
the work you've been doing with Glazer
and with Jay Glazer our buddy
yeah the MVP program and what are you
what have you been up to this is a good
story and I don't know Jay I don't know
if Jay probably likes this version of it
but it was really Nate boy you know Nate
boy is the co-founder of MVP with Jay
because Nate was dealing with a lot of
his transition but a lot of his buddies
in the military and Jay was dealing with
a lot of of his buddies who were
retiring from the NFL and they were
noticing something there was a
correlation between the transition and
how to civilian life if he will
certainly yeah right the idea of both
combat veterans and former players think
we'll never do anything as important
again we just we don't and we need to
find a purpose or repurpose and he
brought us together is what happened so
I was watching what Nate was doing with
Colin Kaepernick and I really thought
that was open-minded and
forward-thinking and I wanted to know
more so I reached out to him via Twitter
and he sure enough reached back out we
went to had breakfast and he says I'm
part of this program would love for you
to come in and be a part of it maybe let
me speak to the veterans and I remember
he walked in and talked to Jay psych I
had breakfast with Ryan Leaf this
morning I wanted to come in and Jays
like oh no don't bring it don't bring
him in here Jane I haven't seen each
other for years in those years this is
just the character of me right when you
said my name you know what four years
ago that would have probably been most
people's answers no keep that guy away
from
as far away as that's bad news and Nate
looked at him said J you don't get to
decide who we who we save and uh I'm
sure that hit J right in the gut you did
a heart and then I showed up and I just
do what I do now and I just speak
honestly and I looked every one of those
veterans in the eyes and told him I'm
just like you just a flawed human being
trying to be better that happened to do
something what people thought was
important at one time and J just well J
was you know dumbfounded by it and since
that moment J has been probably the
biggest supporter of mine when it comes
to my health but also my career he is he
knew what I wanted to do this is what I
went to college for but I'd the last
place I wanted to be was in a newsroom
after I retired I mean the media and I
were juggling water right so that's the
last place I wanted to be and what he's
been able to accomplish for me because
of a program he started and what I've
been able to do vice versa to help Betts
and the vets to help me so it's been
it's been pretty phenomenal I love that
guy glazes just got a huge heart huge
heart but you understand why he had that
reaction when he first of course is your
name right and it doesn't it doesn't
surprise me when somebody has that
reaction even now after what we've been
doing for the last three years since
I've got out of prison
it still doesn't surprise me and it may
be warranted and I don't take it
personally I don't because I mean I
believed it for so long when people such
as in your ilk would talk about me I
started to believe it and go that's
that's who I am
I'm just gonna disappear and go away and
we need people like Nate Boyer to grab
you up say you know what you know we
don't get to decide who we save that's
we just we just do it we'd be part of
the solution yeah the MVP program is
it's awesome what they're doing up there
with unbreakable I got to meet a couple
of the vets who are yeah and that
promise AJ and Denver and those two I
did yeah they're great I mean they're
just it's it's great what what he's
doing and and I'm thrilled what what's
going on in your life these days I want
to come back in 60 seconds and take a
break we're hit this letter that Chris
Brockman doesn't
anything about yet haven't read Mike
have no idea this letter that you sent
to me by direct message two days ago
it's an instant classic well you weren't
you weren't expecting that at all you
were just nobody's expecting this that's
in 60 seconds with Ryan Leaf under it
Johnson show
all right we're back in studio with the
Ryan Leaf who I follow on Twitter you
and I follow each other on Twitter and
it's been great getting back in touch
with you Ryan it really is at Ryan D
leaf on Twitter okay so now we were
chatting about when we we can have you
back in studio here on the show Chris
Brockman he Ryan Leaf sends me a letter
in direct message don't put it up just
yet you sent it to me and I'm like what
the hell is this there's no other way to
put it yeah I'm like is this real you're
like I think it's real this is a letter
okay that has become into Ryan's
possession we'll get into that in a
second as to how it has written in March
of 1998 two Colts owner Jim Irsay you up
at the time a month away and the drafted
decision between you and pavement right
put the letter up
it's from Hunter s Thompson the
brilliant hunter s Thompson yes okay
mr. fear and loathing himself dear Jane
dear James okay March 14th 1998 dear
James in response to your addled request
for a quick 30 million dollar loan to
secure the services of the Manning kid I
have to say no at this time but the leaf
boy is another matter he looks strong
and Manning doesn't or at least not
strong enough to handle that welcome to
the NFL business for two years without a
world-class offensive line how are you
fixed at left ot for the next few years
James think about it you don't want to
try to dial back there when that freak
SAP comes crashing in okay let me know
if you need some money for leaf I expect
to be very rich when this Depp movie
comes out your faithful consultant
hunter and it's signed HST with at the
bottom scrawled in handwriting CC John
Walsh ESPN and CC Colonel Depp
now John Walsh of ESPN is the godfather
of SportsCenter who I've known for 20
some odd years and was hunter s
Thompson's former editor at rolling
stone
he knows Hunter S Thompson for years so
Ryan I say this is real and now you you
said how did you come into possession of
this
I'm the Chicago Cubs fan and they were
in town last week and I was sitting
there behind the dugout and a guy in LA
here in LA and a guy tapped me on the
shoulder and and said are you Ryan are
you Ryan Leaf I said yes sir and and he
said and I'm just you know she's such a
fan of what you're doing now with the
foundation and everything like that and
he just we talked for a little bit he's
like have you ever have you ever seen
that the Hunter s Thompson letter and
I'm like no I don't know what you're
talking about yeah and he's like I grew
up around the corner from from Jimmy
Irsay and I was in Tokyo opening up
DirecTV Japan at the tip yeah
DirecTV Japan and I got this letter
would you like to see it and I said well
yeah of course I mean I didn't believe
it for a second right and there it came
in the email and I showed it to my my
fiancee who's a huge Hunter s Thompson
fan and we read it and I just the
absurdity of the fact that a hunter s
Thompson knew who I was and B that he
was he was tried to persuade mr. Irsay
to draft me instead was just comical and
not to see it for 20 years how does it
it just it's just nowhere to be found
how would it be found right it's and so
you're like let's talk about I'm like
well I just got to see if it's real
first so I googled Hunter s Thompson's
signature looks just like it is the HST
and then I'm like why the hell am I not
just calling John Walsh who I've known
forever I called John Walsh of ESPN and
I spoke with him this morning after
texting with him all over the July 4th
holiday because you sent this to me just
a couple days ago and he says cuz he's
known hunter and his family's known
Hunter s for four years he said his wife
was like why are they thinking it's not
real and as a matter of fact it's a
thousand percent real wow wow it's a
thousand percent real and he told me how
her se hooked up with Hunter s Thompson
to begin with is that Irsay bought in
auction an original copy of on the road
by Jack Kerouac and wanted it verified
as real and reached out to Hunter s
Thompson to verify it and the two of
them hit it off and Hunter S Thompson
was a huge NFL fan who interestingly
enough enough loved Al Davis
and obviously an opinion on the 99 each
well I think now that we know that a lot
of people had an opinion on the 1998 NFL
Draft yes this one in particular just I
just I couldn't I'm still like
speechless to the fact that because this
was an opinion of a lot of people so in
98 people like to say that it wasn't now
in hindsight but this was an opinion of
a lot of people's but that to come from
him and then just the whole process the
fact that we were coming on the show I
could pass along to you you could
actually get it confirmed with John
Walsh at ESPN and yeah he confirmed it
yeah to me this very morning and he goes
you know the colonel Depp is Johnny Depp
I'm like yes John I got that thank you
figured that one out now my question is
is Johnny Depp familiar with the NFL
[Music]
Rolling Stone says he's not familiar
with much in reality right now you know
I'm informed with the Pirates of the
Caribbean movie so yeah you know you
know it's interesting is amazing I love
that line is that you don't want a china
doll back there when that freak SAP
comes crashing in he would go on and
play start the most consecutive games of
anybody
and I would be injured going into here
too and missed the entire season so
we're just just reminding people wrong
underlined yes Jim Morris senior told me
that they were grinding tape on the to
you up until the very day of the draft
yeah and we were we were pretty out of
it I I hadn't made it a mandate to Leigh
Steinberg to say no I didn't want to go
to Indianapolis but in my opinion I was
like I had family on the west coast I
played on the west coast
San Diego June Jones was gonna be my
quarterback coach Kevin Gilbride was
gonna be my head coach mmm Beach money
babes I mean that was that was a life
for me and I wasn't thinking about do I
have Marshall Faulk in the back field
do I have Marvin Harrison out on this
side you know I was not I was was not in
the right mindset to be an NFL
quarterback who thought well I was told
and I will say this to you here that
they asked the same question if you and
Peyton Manning prior to the draft what's
the first thing you knew if you get the
playbook this is what I was told
Manning said I'm gonna get in it right
away and learn it and you said I'm gonna
first thing what I do when I'm drafted
I'm gonna go to Vegas with my buddies is
that a true story well I went with the
Spano sis so I don't know if it was
necessarily though they flew me there
and drop me off and hung out so I but I
doubt that's what I said okay I probably
I probably wasn't asked I've heard a lot
of what Bill Polian has said via that
draft I don't know necessarily if a lot
of it was true it sounds like something
I might say back then okay but I don't
believe that was something I actually
said I probably would have tried to I
was telling people what they wanted to
hear they asked me that question I would
have said oh I'll be on it on the
private jet heading back to the facility
right that's what I would have said but
if you went to Vegas clearly that's why
Hunter s Thompson loved you probably
know fear and loathing there I mean this
this is to me this letter
Ryan is a piece of Americana from one of
the most incredible sports drafts that
we have seen you know I was so blown
away when you sent me I talked to you
know Andrew Perloff yes I know really
well he's on vacation out here right now
oh great I'm so glad he's but I sent
this to him and he was like dude this
that's gonna make a lotta that's gonna
make some news and I'm like no it's not
it's just well we'll see yeah we'll see
but they have Dan and his crew have
another piece of memorabilia of course
in their man cave
it's the jersey that Indianapolis had
prepared that night like 16 leaf Colts
Jersey the things in there man cave so
yeah you're probably right there was a
lot I mean they they had a Jersey made
then there was it was ready to go down
either way but man hey need to be a part
of it I can look now that I know what's
important in life I can look back at
something like this and just be like how
cool it how cool is this right yeah
we're looking at the new autographed it
we're looking at our sister show Dan
Patrick there that isn't the man cave
hey Ryan
it's great to see you let's get you back
here in just a couple of weeks and we'll
talk pac-12 football and we'll get we'll
get ready for this season Hawk 12 Media
Days July 25th okay I'll be there doing
the show from there and talking with all
the guys and getting ready and
I get to call call a few games for the
pac-12 this year fantastic yeah that's
great so let's let's talk college
football let's let's just go deep into
sports and what you're doing pac-12 this
morning channel 373 on sirius XM radio
every single day 10:00 a.m. to 1:00 p.m.
Eastern time 7:00 to 10:00 Pacific time
and then for MVP let's get this out
there vets and players org for emerging
vets and players what you're doing with
with with glaze and Nate Boyer good to
see it you do you got it thanks at Ryan
D Leaf Hunter s Thompson's number one
draft choice here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience